[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
61 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Thanks, Francesc.
All the better because we're in
the same room at the same time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Finally.
For not long, but finally.
MARK MANDEL: For a little bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For a
little bit, just a week.
But yeah, finally back from
Europe and still not in India.
So there you go.
San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we have a
very interesting episode that--
I mean, I'm excited
about it, but I
know that you're even more
excited, because video games.
MARK MANDEL: I seem to be very
excited a lot lately, I've
noticed.
It seems to be a
recurring theme.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're always--
I'm always excited,
but you're always
excited about this episode.
Lately, I've been having
pretty cool episodes.
And actually, the
two next episodes
that we're going to be having--
we already know what they are.
And they're also very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: They're
also very exciting.
Yeah, so this week, we have Rob
Whitehead, CTO at Improbable,
joining us.
Improbable is a company that
helps you build massively
online persistent worlds.
And so we're going
to chat with them.
They run on GCP, and it's
a pretty cool partnership
we also have with them.
So we're going to
talk all about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very interesting conversation.
Talking about
basically, how would
you do it if you had to
build the matrix, kind of.
MARK MANDEL: Kind of, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A very, very
interesting conversation,
that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: I want to
be the architect, though.
I get to be the architect.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You don't
really have that beard, though.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, sorry.
Sorry, no.
MARK MANDEL: That's OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If we
were to have an architect,
we know who that will be,
and he works at Google.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
That's totally true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Anyway, at the end,
we'll have the Question
of the Week, which
is about resizing disks.
Something pretty normal,
and not that exciting.
But you might need to do it at
some point, and knowing this
may make your life
so much easier.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
before that, we're
going to go with our
Cool Things of the Week.
And they're seriously cool.
MARK MANDEL: They
are seriously cool.
I know the first one, you had
a fair bit of involvement in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: I see that
Google Cloud Endpoints is now
generally available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep, we
hit GA, and it is amazing.
That's actually
the topic I'm going
to be talking about
during my Cloud Next
talk in two, three weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
So
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
I think the most interesting--
the cool thing about Cloud
Endpoints is the
fact that it allows
you to do many things
that you need to do,
but without any effort,
such as managing,
you need to do logging,
you need to do monitoring,
you need to do authentication.
You need to do all
of those things.
With Cloud Endpoints,
you get to do
all of those by just
having a Swagger spec,
or [INAUDIBLE]
API specification,
which is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In the
Kelsey-Hightower scale
of dopeness, it's pretty dope.
So it is a very
cool thing to have.
Check it out.
It is now GA, and there's a
bunch of things that it does.
It is supported on GCE,
on GKE, on App Engine
for Java and Python.
And actually, anywhere else.
You can run it anywhere.
We have a small Engine X proxy
that you can run anywhere.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yep, so pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: That is very cool.
Now, the second Cool Thing
of the Week is super cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
mean, globally, it is--
what's the word?
Globally, consistently cool?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is a
globally, consistently cool
Thing of the Week.
Yeah, we released Cloud
Spanner, which is our spanner
product as a service.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so the
public beta for Cloud Spanner--
a globally distributed
relational database service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I mean, it is pretty amazing.
Because if you think about
it, it's basically like,
we had already an
episode on Bigtable.
And Bigtable is
kind of a big deal.
I see Spanner as an
evolution of Bigtable.
Because you're basically
providing things that normally
you only have in
relational databases,
but globally distributed, and
consistently, and available.
Which is kind of crazy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so you
have all your traditional SQL
stuff, so you've got your
SQL, you've got schemas,
you've got consistency.
That's great.
But you've also got
really high availability,
horizontal scaling
basically out the wazoo,
to a global level, and
automatic replication.
And global transactions
and consistency.
It's pretty crazy.
We're going to definitely do
a whole podcast topic on it,
but there's a
couple of blog posts
that you can read
about it right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Definitely
deserves a full episode,
if it's not more than one.
But for those that
might have cringed
when I said that it
is both consistent
and globally available,
that is good to cringe.
We have an article explaining
why it is not really true,
but almost.
MARK MANDEL: True enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is true enough.
It is not completely available,
but the availability's
so high that it is basically
globally available.
So we have a bunch of
links in the show notes
so you can read that [INAUDIBLE]
white paper on Spanner.
But there is also a
bunch of other ones
that you may be interested by.
There's also a bunch
of different tutorials
that you can try.
There's one for Go.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is
pretty nice, but also node.js,
and, I think, Java and
whatever you want to do.
So go have a look.
Play with it.
It is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: It is, indeed.
Cool.
So why don't we go have a chat
with Rob at Improbable, then?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Today we are joined by
a very special guest.
I think they're always
very special guests,
but a very special guest.
Rob Whitehead,
CTO of Improbable.
Rob, how are you doing today?
ROB WHITEHEAD:
Yeah, not bad, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: Very, very well.
Thank you so much for
joining us, coming
to talk to us about
Improbable, about Spatial OS.
Before we get stuck
into that, why
don't you tell us a little
bit about who you are
and what you do?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, sure.
So I'm Rob.
I'm co-founder and CTO of a
tech company called Improbable.
We're based in London,
about 150 of us.
Previously, I'd started
Improbable fresh out of college
in 2012, where I met my
co-founder Herman in Cambridge.
And yeah, my role's
evolved over the years
from working on
our core technology
to now looking after
how the product-- which,
we'll talk more about Spatial
OS as being specifically applied
in the games industry.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So to be honest, for
me, the first time
I heard about
Improbable was when
I read a headline saying
something that "Improbable
Teams with Google."
And I actually didn't
realize it was a company
name, so I had some hard
time parsing the sentence.
Could you tell us a little bit,
for people that don't know,
people that are not, like Mark,
into video games that much.
What is Improbable?
Why is it important?
What do you do?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, sure.
So it's probably worth
telling a little bit
about this kind of story behind
where we got to Spatial OS.
In the early days
hanging out with Herman,
and we had this dream of
a truly living world video
game, whereby traditional
games are constrained
either in terms of
their scale or in terms
of the fidelity of the world.
So you'll get a very large,
open-world games which
are very limited interaction.
Or you get very, very smaller
more high-fidelity worlds,
like a game like Battlefield.
And we wanted to build a game
that was a truly living world,
where there were
millions of trees,
or millions of
animals, monsters.
And the players themselves
were completely incidental
inside that world, and
it had huge amounts
of physical fidelity.
And we knew we'd never seen
games like that before.
And we knew that
this necessarily
would require us to come
up with a way of having
multiple computers in the
cloud cooperate together
to simulate the same space,
because the world was going
to be too rich and too
large for a single machine
to be able to deal with.
And as we evolved, we moved from
our early prototypical ideas
of building a game into building
this foundational simulation
platform, which is
what we're doing now.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, so you've built this
platform called Spatial OS.
What can you do inside of it?
Is it just games?
What's the possibilities?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Spatial
OS is a platform
for building simulated worlds.
So what do I mean by that?
Any problem you have which
involves a set of entities
which are things,
and they interact
in unexpected and complex
ways, and the scale
of those interactions and the
fidelity of those interactions
is so large that
you want to be using
the power of multiple
machines, Spatial OS nails.
So if you're trying to simulate
a very huge game world,
then you're going to have
lots of player entities,
you're going to have monsters,
trees, inventory items.
If you're simulating
a city, those entities
might be cars, road segments,
traffic signals, pedestrians,
buildings.
And it really depends on
what domain you're modeling.
And to get sort of
formal about it,
it's in the realm of
complex systems modeling.
It's modeling systems
where you have
lots of little
things interacting,
and then you get crazy emergent
consequences from that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So this is the Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
Usually, we talk about how
you use Google Cloud Platform.
But as well as that,
I think it's worth
noting there's a partnership
here between Google Cloud
Platform and Improbable as well.
Do you want to talk a
bit about how that works,
and what that provides
for developers?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, I think
both Improbably and Google
agree, [INAUDIBLE] Spatial OS
lets people build fundamentally
new kinds of game
experience with these very
massive, simulated,
meaningful worlds,
but also lets
smaller teams do so.
And the idea of our
games innovation program
is about enabling
game developers
to get credits to
start developing
with Spatial OS for free.
And essentially have
credit, so that rather
than when you're
developing your game,
you have to pay for
the compute being used,
you only have to pay for
the compute after launch.
So it's about helping
you get up and running,
and not be afraid of really
pushing the boundaries
in terms of what you can do.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So GCP's partnering with you to
help power that whole program.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Perfect.
And if people are
interested in the program,
or they want to build something
on Spatial OS for that program,
is there any information
upcoming or available
right now?
ROB WHITEHEAD:
Yeah, so we're going
to be announcing the specifics
of the program closer
towards GDC.
But right now, anybody who
signs up through SpatialOS.com
will be eligible to
apply for the program.
And so if anyone's
interested in going through,
I'd recommend they
go to SpatialOS.com
and go through those steps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I wanted to learn a
little bit about how--
you said that there's the
name of the OS, Spatial OS.
Is it really an OS?
What does it look
to be a developer
and to build something
on top of it?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, sure.
I mean, that's a
really good question.
So Spatial OS is a kind
of [INAUDIBLE] distributed
operating system.
So when you have
traditional operating
systems like Android, Windows,
they run on a single machine.
Spatial OS is a
layer above that,
which lets you take
multiple computers
and consider them to
be one, big computer
and present an abstraction
on top of that.
So specifically, Spatial
OS runs on top of a core OS
on a cluster of
machines in the cloud,
and then gives you APIs
so you can treat it
as almost one,
big supercomputer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So it sounds like it's video
game-specific Kubernetes,
almost?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, I guess
the core abstraction is
you look at traditional-- well,
it's a platform as a service.
And you look at kind
of traditional problems
as a service.
The early days, we had tools
like Google App Engine, which
are about a stateless
web application
with some persistent
data back-end.
And that was great for a
certain group of people.
If you want to build a
[INAUDIBLE] mobile back-end,
or you want to build a web
app, you can just nail that out
really fast.
And then you had more
flexible platforms
like Google Cloud
Functions, which
let you have these transient
pieces of computation
acting and responding to
things like [INAUDIBLE] bus.
And from our side, we
found there wasn't really
a platform within
an abstraction that
was really about creating
these large-scale simulated
environments.
And Spatial OS, we felt
like it filled that end.
And so rather than thinking
about your clustered machines
as a set of a bag of containers,
like with Kubernetes,
you think about your
clustered machines
as a three-dimensional space.
And it's a pretty
crazy abstraction,
but it actually works.
So you think of your cluster as
a huge three-dimensional space.
And inside of it,
you put entities.
And those entities are the
things I talked about before.
In your city simulation, they're
your vehicles, your roads,
your traffic signals.
In your video game, they're
players, monsters, loots--
all that kind of stuff.
And then under the hood,
we're partitioning up
the data and computation of
that world across a cluster
behind the scenes for you.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
if I'm a developer who
wants to build
something on Spatial OS,
what does that development
flow look like?
I think you mentioned maybe
there are command line tools?
Or how do I build
something from start
to finish with, say, an
engine like maybe Unity
or something else?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So it's worth saying
from our side,
we really believe
in people taking
the tools they're
already familiar with
to use our technology.
So let's say you're
traditionally
used to building a dedicated
server-based multiplayer
game in Unity.
You'd have a Unity-dedicated
server probably built out,
Linux running,
and you'd probably
put it on some either dedicated
machine or on some VM.
And you'll tell some clients,
go and connect to that.
And so with Spatial OS,
you download our SDK,
which is just a series
of command line tools,
and web UIs, essentially.
And you get plugins
which actually
tie into whatever game
engine you're using.
So whether you're using
Unreal, or using Unity,
or you're using your
own game engine,
this essentially handles your
connection into Spatial OS
and handles taking the part of
the world which your engine is
simulating and synchronizing
it with the broader world.
And yeah, you pretty much
have business as usual.
So, like I said, once you've
built your application using
your game engine of
choice, you build that
out into what we call an
assembly, which is almost
like a distributed executable.
It's this application
which you're
going to push into our
platform, and it's going
to run across lots of machines.
And from that, you just use
a single CLI command, just
spatial deploy.
And it takes your built-out
Unity application,
and it pushes it
into our platform.
And then it carves out
those VMs and that cluster
behind the scenes, and
then instantly, you've
got a simulated world running
there up in the cloud.
And the next step is you
can take a URL to that
and share it with a friend,
and have both of you log in.
MARK MANDEL: Cool,
but does that mean
I have to write in some
sort of custom language?
Am my escaping my
usual set of tools?
How does that work?
ROB WHITEHEAD: No, you can use
your existing set of tools,
be it Unity,
Unreal, Game Engine,
or whatever kind of tool you
want to be using for that.
The thing which binds
this all together,
and the kind of magic,
is traditionally,
worlds would be built or run
from having a single dedicated
server running in the cloud.
Now, there's a
cluster of machines.
So concretely, for a
game like Worlds Adrift,
we're actually running
hundreds of instances
of a game engine like Unity in
the cloud cooperating together
to simulate a world much
bigger than any single one
of those engines
could ever understand.
And then plugging
into the world,
as well, you can have
well over 1,000 clients
interacting in the same
physical environment.
And again, that's much
larger than a single game
engine could ever deal with.
And that's because Spatial OS is
a distributed cluster handling
the in-memory persistence of all
those entities as they mutate,
handling the network fan-out
of you moving around the world
and having all the things
you're seeing streamed into you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So going on the
developer experience of Spatial
OS, I'm curious about if the
"Hello World" of Map Reduce
is counting words, what is the
"Hello World" of Spatial OS?
ROB WHITEHEAD: So if you
go through our GitHub,
you'll find there's actually
an example, game simulation we
call "Hello World."
And it really is trying to
demonstrate the core aspects
of what the technology does.
So "Hello World," there is--
I guess we coined this term,
[INAUDIBLE], which, I don't
know if it's going to catch on.
It was this idea of this "Hello
World" project has two teams,
and the two teams are
running at each other,
and these little wizards.
And they start with very
small amounts of characters.
And they build up,
and up, and up,
until there are thousands a
side, attacking each other.
And the cloud deployment has two
instances of Unity overlapping
and co-simulating to
simulate the entire space.
So it's a good example
of something showing
an interesting game environment
with emerging complexity
and interesting
gameplay mechanics.
It's got the two workers
cooperating together,
demonstrating that
Spatial OS is letting
you use more than one machine.
And yeah, that's the
foundational thing
you tend to jump off from.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I've played it.
There's lots of fire.
It's fun.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah,
Mark set me on fire.
It wasn't very friendly.
MARK MANDEL: That's
what friends are for.
Cool.
All right, so now
I'm also curious.
So Spatial OS sounds great.
Platform as a service for all
these massively online games.
Why does Spatial OS, Improbable,
use Google Cloud Platform?
What are you using
on us as products?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, sure.
So although as a developer,
you interact with Spatial OS,
under the hood, with
the Innovation Program,
we run on Google Compute Engine
to actually run those VMs.
So when you create a
Spatial OS deployment,
you're going to be using
Google VMs to get requisitioned
and start.
And the thing we
found with Google VMs
is specifically around
their provisioning time.
So say if you're a small
group of indie devs,
and you're trying
to do a game jam,
and you want to be iterating
rapidly and pushing
your simulation to the cloud,
having a tight provisioning
loop is really
good, because it's
the amount of time you
go from a CLI command
to actually having a game
running in the cloud you
can go and play.
And we found GCE was
specifically good for that.
And the other side,
which is something
to bear in mind with games
is a lot of the web is built
around TCP, is built
around these cross-response
connections, a lot of JSON.
And when you move towards
applications like games,
you're actually dealing with
firehoses of unreliable UDP
packets.
And traditionally,
a lot of clouds
haven't really been set up to
be particularly good at routing
that kind of traffic.
And from our side, we
found Google Cloud Platform
was a good choice in terms
of games networking as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I think that on top of
using Google Cloud Platform,
you might have also been
using other Google open source
projects.
You mentioned [INAUDIBLE],
and [INAUDIBLE]--
I think their headline is
something like, "Google
infrastructure for everyone."
Are you using
something like GRPC?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, there's
actually plenty of stuff
to talk about.
The first thing, yeah, is GRPC.
Although the core
entity synchronization
things within our tech
are kind of bespoke,
the platform itself, in terms
of requisitioning deployments,
getting metadata--
all that, we use GRPC.
And the reason we
like that is-- one
is very, very easy streaming
responses based upon HTTP2.
And the other side as well
is having that kind of binary
serialization by default.
And also having a typed RPC
system by default
as well, rather than
throwing around JSON.
We found it was perfect
for our use cases.
And I guess another thing in the
Google space we use is Basel.
When you're building
a simulation platform,
you're building APIs which can
be used in C#, C++, JavaScript,
Java.
And a tool like Basel lets
you handle a mono repo, which
has a load of different
languages working together
in the same build.
So we found that invaluable
in terms of scaling
as an engineering organization.
MARK MANDEL: So, it's
actually interesting.
Normally, when I hear
people using this many tools
from Google open source
world especially,
they're normally ex-Googlers.
You're not ex-Googlers
though, right?
ROB WHITEHEAD: So a few people
from our infrastructure team
are ex-Googlers, and there's a
certain bit of that in there.
We have a good cross-section
of different people.
And a tech like
Spatial OS, you need
to have this weird blend of--
we have the ex-large-scale
software companies
to give that production
and scale stuff.
You've got people from
high-frequency trading firms,
so they use that kind
of really low latency,
high-throughput interactions.
And you have people
from the gaming industry
who are around all the
tricks and all of the skills
which go into building a
very efficient game engine,
for example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I guess
then, the next question
is, are you hiring?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yes, we are.
So we actually have
offices in San Francisco.
We just set up recently there.
We also have our home base
in Farringdon in London.
So we have a lot of
us hanging out there.
And yeah, we're always
looking for people
who are interested in this
kind of thing in terms
of building large-scale,
reliable infrastructure,
and simulating the world.
Or building the matrix.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So curious, though--
so you're building,
it seems like, almost
a very different type
of platform from what
people have built before.
What were some
interesting challenges
you faced when
building Spatial OS?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
We had many, many
challenges on our quest.
It's definitely,
definitely worth saying.
Some fun stories to
talk about there.
One is when you start running--
normally a game will run
with a single server,
binary running in the cloud.
And occasionally, it'll crash.
So the stuff is
high-performance C++ code.
Sometimes, it's
going to have issues.
Yeah, so traditionally, when you
run a single dedicated server,
you'll find that.
It's written in high-performance
C++ code, and occasionally,
it might crash.
But what happens when
you run 100 instances,
or 1,000 instances of
that kind of game server
code at the same time, as
a swarm of microservices?
Statistically speaking,
the probability
of any one of them
failing goes up and up.
So we had to bake into
the core of our platform
the fact that these
workers can fail.
And how that works
is we actually
have the in-memory
representation of the world.
So every entity, every
player, rock, character
has an in-memory representation
within the Spatial OS
runtime of the state.
And these workers are
almost streaming processes,
that they're pulling in the
data of the world around it,
simulating parts of
the world and streaming
that back into Spatial OS.
So at a moment's notice, if any
of those workers were to fail,
we can rush in and
actually replace them
with another worker who can
be given that information
to continue the computation.
So that's one
really fun problem.
I say fun in retrospect.
Obviously, they were incredibly
tough things to get through.
So I guess one of the most
interesting challenges we
had to solve is the fact
that physics engines, when
you run a single
instance of them,
they'll actually
use non-determinism
in how they solve their
physics to actually increase
the numerical stability
of the result.
So you can imagine
a big pile of boxes
being simulated by the
algorithms inside of them.
By randomly shuffling
the order which
those things are processed,
you end up with a better result
mathematically.
But when you start to have
1,000 instances of those physics
engines overlapping and
cooperating together,
you get these
really fun scenarios
where you'll have overlap
regions, where both of them
are interested in
the same world.
And they might actually simulate
slightly different responses.
So from that side, we
had to produce strategies
and algorithms for essentially
blending their truths together
after a set amount of time.
And that was a really
interesting challenge
where now, we can actually
stack a pile of boxes
on top of each other
whilst migrating
the authority of those boxes
between two physics engines
multiple times a second, and
the physics simulation is still
stable.
So that's the way we think
about it is almost eventually
consistent physical simulation.
And like I said,
that was something
we invested a lot of
effort in the early years.
MARK MANDEL: My
head's exploding!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I could see.
[LAUGHING]
ROB WHITEHEAD: Is
that too crazy?
MARK MANDEL: No, I'm
just thinking about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It does make sense.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it makes sense,
but the non-determinism--
ROB WHITEHEAD: I've got
another little cheeky soundbite
thing I can say.
The line of dominoes is
actually my favorite one
to describe the technology.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, go on.
ROB WHITEHEAD: I guess
one of the easiest ways
to break down Spatial OS
into its most base example
is a game which we're
not planning on making,
but let's call it
Domino Simulator 2017.
So in Domino Simulator 2017,
there are 1 million dominoes.
And you can flick the
domino on the right side
and have it cascade, cascade.
And eventually, it'll knock over
the domino on the far left side
a million down.
Imagine you wanted to
simulate that in real-time
and have people able to
participate and see that.
The issue is, a single
physics engine wouldn't
be able to simulate the
physics of a million dominoes
at the same time.
But we probably
have physics engines
that could simulate
maybe 1,000, 10,000
dominoes at the same time.
So let's say we actually
bring up 1,000 physics engines
all next to each other to
simulate that entire set of 1
million dominoes.
Well, you're going
to get an issue where
when you flick the
domino on the far right,
and it starts cascading
down, you get to the point
where it needs to interact
with the next physics engine.
And this is a very,
very difficult problem.
And the way it works
is you can think
of every entity, every domino
in the simulation to have
almost a bubble around it.
Imagine that, a bubble of half
a meter in real-life terms.
And you can think
about, if I were
to simulate the physics for
that single domino, what
other things could actually act
on that at any point in time
to effect it?
Well, maybe the
dominoes very nearby it.
But the domino a
million dominoes away
might eventually affect
it, but it's not going
to instantaneously affect it.
And this idea of
bubbles of simulation
and synchronizing the right
data to the right physics
engines at the
right point in time
is a lot of what the core hard
technical problems of Spatial
OS are all about.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is pretty cool.
So we were talking a little
bit before about "Hello World"
and what are the
basic things that you
can build with Spatial OS.
What about the other
side of things?
What is the biggest
game you know that has
been built with Spatial OS?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Interesting.
So I can talk about games.
The other thing I
want to talk about
is some of the more
geographically explosive things
that are non-games applications.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
ROB WHITEHEAD: So
specifically one example
is where somebody came in
for a week to jam with us,
and they had knowledge in
internet network routing.
So essentially,
that border gateway
protocol, which is how all
the nodes of the internet
find out how to read each other.
And they simulated
every single node, just
45,000 nodes in
the entire internet
and could have a real-time
simulation of how
those nodes reacted to failure.
So you could be like,
what happens if I
pull out this [? plow ?] cable?
How will the internet react?
And how will it move around its
routing of internet traffic?
And that kind of thing
was really exciting.
Seeing a small group
of people come in,
they model some interactions
between two entities,
the well-known set
of interactions.
And then they could scale
it up to this massive scale.
And I think that one of
the fun things about BGP
is every single node has to know
about every single other node
and how to route to it.
So you get this really
fun, every single node
has every other node's
routing information in it.
So it grows with very,
very fun memory complexity.
So it was interesting seeing
how much memory we had
to consume to actually do that.
MARK MANDEL: So that
sounds super interesting.
Do you have any numbers you
could share in terms of how big
or small that was?
Or how many entities were being
used inside that simulation?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, so with
our internet simulations,
it's more about the
entities themselves
being very heavy-weight
and doing a lot
of algorithmic complexity.
There are other simulations
in our city simulation
space, which are in the
order of tens of millions
of entities in terms of
representing buildings, roads,
traffic segments,
vehicles, pedestrians,
which are pretty exciting.
And then in terms of our
gaming applications or games
like Worlds Adrift,
which are using millions
of entities interacting there.
And they represent either from
a tree which you can chop,
and it will physically fall
over and break into pieces,
to creatures that fly around,
and they mate with each other
and have a real
ecology around them,
to players building ships
out of physical parts.
So you can build a
floating sky ship out
of hundreds of different
panels, and engines, and guns,
and different pieces.
And every single
one of those things
is an entity which
is persistent.
So if you crash into another
ship, and one of those panels
falls over and
lands on the ground,
that will actually
persist indefinitely,
because it's stored
inside Spatial OS's
in-memory representation,
which, again, is regularly
snapshotted out.
So even if someone goes away
and comes back again later,
it'll still be there.
Because rather than
having the transient stay
inside of these game
engines, it's actually
in a persistent layer on top.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, so we're slowly
running out of time.
Where can people go if people
want to go to events or things
like that?
What upcoming events
or appearances
are you all going to be at?
ROB WHITEHEAD:
Yeah, I think it's
a big couple of weeks for us.
I think the first stop
is, as I said, GDC.
So if you go to
SpatialOS.com/GDC,
this is going to be telling
about the events we're running
there.
We're going to be
running some panels.
We're going to be doing a couple
of on-stage presentations.
And we'll also have a booth
nearby Google Cloud Platform,
actually.
People can come and find us.
We're going to be putting on
some evening events, which
you can find out more
through that link.
And after that, the week
after is going to be GCP Next,
and we're going to
be hanging out there.
I know Herman, our
CEO, is doing a talk.
I'm going to be on-stage with
Mark, talking about some more
Spatial OS.
It's going to be good fun.
And yeah, that's
probably the next things
on our radar for events.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
have one more question
that I need to ask before we
finish the interview, which
is why is the company
called Improbable?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Oh, that's
a really good story.
I don't know-- let's see
where you can go with this.
So actually, if you look at
our legal incorporation status,
the name is Improbable Worlds.
And I remember we hired a
very, very edgy design agency,
and they were
hanging out with us.
And I remember the last
thing they said to us--
they were like,
"Drop the 'worlds.' "
And then walked out in a kind
of quite enigmatic fashion.
So yeah, I guess the
other side is it really
has come to reflect
a lot of the values
we have as a company,
really about trying
to do things that haven't
been done before and felt,
and specifically, these
large-scale simulations.
So it's something we like.
It's something which
definitely caught on.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Rob, thank you
so much for joining us.
We really appreciate
you taking the time,
and it's been a
great conversation.
ROB WHITEHEAD: No,
thanks very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
So thanks so much to Rob for
such an interesting interview.
I learned a lot.
And I've got to say
that after talking
so much about all the kind
of simulations you can do,
I want to try it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah it's
really, really, cool tech,
and loads of fun to work with.
Getting huge amounts of things
interacting with each other,
it produces really
interesting behaviors.
And weird stuff
happens, and it's fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I don't
even want to build a game.
I just want to build
a little simulation,
you know, like the Game of Life?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, or
like Ants or something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I just want
to build something like that.
It sounds super cool.
Maybe during my
trips, who knows?
But before we finish
with the podcast,
we have our Question
of the Week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I'll
ask the Question of the Week.
So in Google Cloud Platform,
we have these things
called persistent disks.
We normally mount those
on virtual machines
so that you can write files
to them, and put data in them,
and all that sort of fun stuff.
Sometimes, disks fill up,
and that tends to be bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So one
option is to delete stuff
off disk, which you may
or may not want to do.
The other option is just
make the disk bigger.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Or add more disks.
MARK MANDEL: Or add more disks.
But let's go with
making a disk bigger.
I think that's just easier.
Is there a way I can
make a disk bigger
while not having to
take down my machine,
or turn it off, or do
anything like that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So this is
actually very interesting,
because I think that the
first time I had this question
was during a GCP 100 training.
And I thought the
answer was, well,
you can create a
snapshot of the disk,
then create a new disk that is
bigger based on the snapshot
so you have the same data,
and then swap the disks.
MARK MANDEL: That
doesn't sound like fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
mean, it is doable.
But it turns out
that I was wrong.
Or now, I am wrong, in any case.
Because there's a way easier
way to do it, which is,
you just go to the
console, and then
you click on Edit on the
disk, and you resize it.
No matter if it's attached
to an instance or not,
you can actually do this, which
is an amazing thing to do.
And then the second
part that you need to do
is you actually need to let
the OS that you're running on
that instance realize that
the disks changed its size.
So you might need to change
the size of-- so for instance,
if you're doing Linux, I think
there's a command called Resize
to [? Fd-something? ?]
MARK MANDEL: I
think that's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You can follow
the documentation for that one,
because Resize to
[? Fd-something ?] might not be
the actual accurate name.
But basically, that's
what you need to do.
You first resize
it from the console
and, that is independent
for whatever system
you might be running.
And then according
to the system,
you need to resize
that partition.
And that's it.
So you basically
are able to resize
any disk with zero downtime.
Except if the disk
is a root disk.
If it is a root disk,
then you still need
to go through that older process
that I was talking about,
where you create first
a snapshot of the disk,
and then you create a new
disk based on that snapshot.
So you can still do it.
It's a little bit harder.
Which kind of makes
sense, because root disks
are root and special.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And they have the
operating system on them,
and other fun things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So it is a little bit more
complicated to handle with.
But, yeah, I think
it is a simple thing.
And it's so simple
that sometimes, you
don't think about the
fact that you can just
click on Edit and change
things while they're running,
and everything just works.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Wonderful.
All right, well, Francesc, are
you doing anything interesting?
Are you jet-setting
around some more?
I know you like to
pop around a bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I never
do interesting things.
I never do interesting things.
Actually, today's Wednesday,
which means that tomorrow,
Thursday, I will be speaking
at Go SF for the Go 1.8 release
party.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Lots of
really cool things coming on
with Go 1.8, so we're going
to be talking about those.
I'm specifically going to
be talking about context,
Go context.
But there will be other talks
about the different topics that
are new to the new release.
Then the week after that, I
will go to GopherCon India,
which will be in Pune.
Which, by the way, we received
an email saying that it is
actually pronounced "Pu-neh."
So thank you so much.
Now I know.
MARK MANDEL: I think we
actually got more than one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes,
so thank you so much.
Now I know it's
pronounced "Pu-neh."
So very excited about that.
And then I'll be a
couple of days in Mumbai.
I'm trying to organize
an event in there.
Then I'm coming
back for Cloud Next.
And then I'm leaving
again for GopherCon Con
China in Shanghai, and I'm
very excited by that one.
MARK MANDEL: Oof!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't travel.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: What about me?
So I will be at Game
Developers' Conference.
I'll be everywhere,
just everywhere.
I think I'm just going
to be everywhere.
We are hosting the
Google Developer Day.
I'll be doing a sponsor talk
first thing Wednesday morning
for Google Cloud.
I'll be doing a Lightning Talk
on the Developer Day as well.
We're also sponsoring
a variety of events
around the conference,
including Women in Games,
and Girls make Games,
and things like that.
It's going to be loads, and
loads, and loads of fun.
After that, yes, I'll
be at Next as well.
We'll both be at Next,
doing our podcast thing
and doing some talks.
Strangely enough, one
with Improbable myself.
Once we're done
with that, it looks
like I might be doing
some stuff in Vancouver.
I need to travel up
there for some stuff.
But we'll wait and see
what's happening there.
But after that, I'm doing
a little East Coast tour.
I'll be doing the East
Coast Game Conference.
That'll be the 18th of April.
And then right after
that, I'll be traveling up
to the Vector Conference
in Kentucky on the 21st.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Sounds like lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: It's going
to be lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I guess it's time to finish.
But before we finish, we have
not done this in quite a while.
So let's go through
all our different ways
of people contacting us.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So we have Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And Google+.
MARK MANDEL: @+GCPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we have a web page.
MARK MANDEL: GCPpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: With an email.
MARK MANDEL: @HelloGCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: At
hello GCP podcast?
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
hello GCP podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello@GCPpodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: That works, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Complicated.
And then we are also on Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /r/GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
finally, we are on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: The #podcast
channel on the Google Cloud
Platform community
Slack, which can be found
on bit.ly/GCP-slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
What a mouthful.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
And yeah, send us
your questions,
your messages telling us if
we're misspelling things--
misspelling, mispronouncing.
We probably misspell things,
but you cannot see them.
And also, if you have
any ideas for episodes,
we are always looking
forward to your comments.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Yeah, and if you want
to come on the podcast,
feel free to reach out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
So anyway, thank
you so much again
for an improbable episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
and thank you very
much to everyone for listening.
And see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep, see you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]